on va passer maintenant à aucun d'heure
sans filtre avec une enquête sur quatre
mariages et une lune de miel alors je
vous le dis c'est incroyable ce qui se
passe sur quatre mariages et une lune de
miel ou vous a fait un petit
récapitulatif de tout ce qui se passe
dans l'émission récapitulatif en images
on à mohamed qui sera avec nous et on
aura un autre témoin flore il y en a une
qui a vécu un cauchemar je vous le dis
depuis divorce après quatre mariages et
une lune de miel
elle est au bout du rouleau elle va nous
raconter tout ça et vous allez voir les
méthodes de cette émission c'est parti
récap on y va être mariages pour une
lune de miel c'est une compétition entre
quatre couples qui jugent et notent leur
mariage j'espère que vous allez passer
une excellente soirée une émission nous
raconte des belles histoires d'amour qui
font rêver dans la cour de récréation du
lycée pour me faire remarquer auprès
d'elle je n'ai rien trouvé mieux que
d'aller lui taxer un roux de glace à
l'eau une émission il ya beaucoup
d'amour mais vraiment beaucoup
[Musique]
et où les candidats de ce juge selon
cinq critères son repas de mariage 11
sur 20 l'ouverture de balles 13 sur 20
l'ambiance générale 12,7 sur 20 et dans
cette compétition devant les caméras
tout le monde s'aime et c'est assez
gentille et ses supports avec toi merci
c'est gentil il derrière on sème un peu
moins souhaiterait au ritz voit la
décoration ne correspond pas à santé les
choses que j'ai peu goûté n'était pas
beaucoup et forcément on a le droit à
toutes les animations classiques des
mariages foyer marqué le but là-bas et
vous fallait marquer bethenod allez
c'est parti
[Musique]
mais à chaque fois c'est l'amour qui
triomphe
tu es la seule qui m'a je te le dis sans
faille gênante un programme qui réunit
en moyenne un million deux cent mille
téléspectateurs
[Applaudissements]
on a deux témoins qui sont là et deux
témoins qui ont vécu des aventures
complètement différente on à mohamed qui
est avec nous vous avez participé avec
flore d'ailleurs qui hélas ne vous
n'étiez pas ensemble un jeu de charles
président et au mariage spécial wedding
planners alors qu'est ce qu'un weeding
planners beinheim c'est laisser une
personne qui organise votre mariage et
qui fait tout les en main est exact du
trail et permet d'allier val organisera
également votre coup l'émission ne s'est
pas du tout passé comme prévu puisque
depuis votre passage
votre commerce a commencé à s'effondrer
tout d'abord on a une image de fou avec
anissa donc la mariée dont vous
prépariez le mariage au moment de
l'émission
et c'était avant tout ça tout allait
bien encore et après vous ça a été un
cauchemar c'est lui qui a divorcé aider
à vous à nous raconter vous avez vécu un
nez un cauchemar avec cette émission
mohamed va nous raconter tout ça et je
vois que vous êtes le frère de jean
michel mr et un truc regarde et pour
être sûre que ses invités soient
transportés que tout soit parfait à nice
a fait appel à mohamed wedding planner
depuis cinq ans le mage un message le
sens très bien
pascal a des bonnes idées c'est
exactement ce cadeau
alors pour moi il ya une chose qui est
très importante le jour du mariage c'est
mon arrivée à la salle
je revends quelque chose de wavre j'ai
une idée pour une arrivée extraordinaire
avec moi mes côtés
je pense que j'ai eu 90 % de chances de
remporter la ligne damier
on va parler avec vous dans l'instant
warez mais déjà est-ce que 4 mariages
pour une lune de miel est une émission
trop trash où vous pose la question vous
a préparé un recap en images du style
vous pensez pas que c'est trop
travailleurs iraniens va regarder
regardez pour la plupart d'entre nous
mariage rime avec joie de vivre fait et
bonne humeur mais dans quatre mariages
sur tf1 ce n'est pas toujours le cas
son mariage avec un catastrophe du tbhc
merci ok d'accord
lol et oui souvent les échanges entre
les participantes sont très tendues il
ya des limites à vraiment pas dépasser
dépose petite pisseuse quand jamais ravi
de leur vie tadic moi j'étais le gars
mon mariage tu as vu comment tu t'es
présente à mon mariage
tassé le déballage aussi ta poitrine
tékitoi mais je ne suis pas mais là il
est où le respect mais je suis pas mais
là tu voudrais pas mais pour gagner
alors 4 mariages pour une lune de miel
une émission trop trash alors très vite
répondait qui pensent que c'est qu'ils
pensent que c'est rageant mais tim gunn
il bien sûr c'est volontairement trash
ah oui et c'est pour ça qu'on attend
cette émission et c'est pour ça aussi
qu'elle fonctionne autant là dessus il
ya un aspect pervers avec les mariés qui
soudent note à chaque fois les
différentes candidates et d'ailleurs
vous savez sur la scène de fin le
vendredi
ce qu'on voit pas c'est que souvent
c'est été coupée il ya eu des insultes
et parfois il ya des bagarres qui ont
débuté alors là la prod alliés dont on
arrête le tournage ont su sport vous
calmer alors on met les choses en place
c'est évidemment c'est volontairement
trash pour donner un petit peu de
piquant
oui ou non vous répondez kelly vous
n'êtes pas d'accord oui comme tu dis les
bagarres ont été coupées donc ce n'est
pas trash est ce que tu as déjà vu est
elle arrêtée dans les pays étrangers aux
états-unis en anglais mais cette
émission existe 2011 et il ya eu 450
mariage dans les 450 ya pas eu forcément
toujours des bagarres fontaine
exténué trois prétendantes au
complètement quitté un mariage vous le
dis puisque est ce qu'il y ait un qui a
des bidonnages des paysans c'est dans
cette émission vous à nous en parler
flore et mohamed et d'ailleurs l'année
dernière vous allez voir trois
prétendantes ont complètement quitté
hama je pense qu'on a je ne prie pas
défense
[Musique]
partir jeanne hulot
bonne chance pareille ne s'est pas
compris pourquoi son parti comme ça je
trouve que c'est la moindre des
politesses sont restés pour moi jusqu'au
bout et de dire au revoir aux deux
marques
alors vous est ce que pointent alors est
ce qu'il ya des bidonnages est ce qu'il
ya des magouilles gilles verdez avait
enquêté sur cette émission à prônera le
témoignage de rebelles et de fleurs
alors il ya des noms bidonnage je vous
cite un exemple juillet 2010 cet attrape
un mariage qui a été tourné dégénère il
ya une immense bagarre réel dans le
mariage entre des invités et même des
cadreurs qui sont protagonistes de la
bagarre
qu'est ce qu'a fait la production ils
ont tout beau mais c'est normal ce soit
normal ou pas c'est pas quoi là mais ils
ont tout effacer le mariage est devenu
un super mariage et les mariés qui
étaient là pour juger ont été évacués
sont partis ils ont retourné une scène
bidonné pour justifier leur absence
ça c'est faux voyez ce que je veux dire
on peut dire c'est normal de couper mais
c'est pas normal de réécrire une
histoire tout est scénarisé
il ya un livre de mort dès qu'on déborde
du livre de bord la production dit non
biden alors vous moi mais vous n'avez
pas trop apprécié le montage d'une
séquence en particulier dans l'émission
celle de l'église
on y aperçoit le prêtre vous démentez me
demandez de vous taire ça vous vouliez
le coupé c'est ça c'est pas de me couper
en étant dans l'église et le prêtre
était en train de célébrer le mariage
religieux qui ont bien sûr fort mal en
été on va dire à plusieurs 3,4 bande
arrière et
il y avait du monde dans l'église et
d'un seul coup au bon tout le monde
parlait on égalise et d'un seul coup la
caméra elle s'est fixé sur moi oui c'est
comme si c'est moi qui parle est
d'accord mais quand j'ai vu le montage
et dix reprises des soucis qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pour vous avec cette
émission alors cette émission j'ai pas
où tout allait bien vous étiez marié
vous vous étiez vous participez à la
spéciale weeding planeur donc vous
organiser un mariage
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après
maintenant on n'est pas face à face à au
départ je me sentais donc gens naissent
des mariages depuis quelques années 4
nages et une de miel sedar le site de
production vont contacter régulièrement
pour me demander des mariés oui pas
comme organisateur uniquement des mariés
et j'avais vu deux ou trois fois dans
l'émission se maintient c'est pas parce
que moi en général ils tirent un peu des
chignons dans l'aviation et des cas donc
du coup j'ai à chaque fois je refusais
et un jour on m'appelle au téléphone on
me demande justement de participer les
missions comme organisateur et ça et vu
que moi je suis un peu aventurier donc
j'ai accepté mais bon c'est pas d'accord
non plus aventuriers derrière
maintenant j'ai mon nom y aurait pas
demandé non je n'ai servi dans le sens
qu'il honnit pourquoi pas oui j'ai dit
pourquoi pas donc a eu un premier
casting qui sont venus et ils m'ont
demandé de trouver des mariés que j'ai
contacté des mariés à partir de là je
leur ai proposé des mariés qu'ils
avaient acceptée et le project qui avait
pratiquement plus de deux mois avant
qu'ils me proposent d'accord est-ce
qu'on peut passer des choses parce que
son âge là c'est vrai que quand je
l'organisé
il m'appelait du temps d'accord oui
alors donc voilà après quand j'ai vu le
montage et comment s'est passé des mois
à le détruire
mais qu'est ce qui vous a valu toit des
toiles on va voir je lisais déjà qui t'a
pas plus regardes et tu va nous dire
mariage suppose
peut les y pousse engage la envers
l'autre
ils se promettent un amour mutuel est
resté pour toutes leur ai dit à mon
agent que l'émail est très concentré et
vous plaît les bavardages c'est fini
alors voilà donc moi mais franchement
c'est est plutôt gentil ce qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur les
bidonnages des structures inquiéter les
gens mais si j'ai eu quelqu'un de
téléphone cet après midi suite à un
appel à témoin j'avais lancé et inquiète
par des réponses à mes charges prévu je
serai bien d'accord côté is lucet
[Rires]
j'ai avancé à visage découvert alors eh
voilà qui m'a dit que la l1 rien contre
l'émission mais en revanche oui et les
villages dans ce sens que par exemple
quand on leur demande leur témoignage
sur comment ça s'est passé comment la
trouvez le maillage chistera quand il
commence à s'exprimer
ils arrêtent un mâle madix attentes en
l'occurrence on avait arrêté en
attendant honnêtement tu peux être
gentille tu veux mais je peux dire que l
est a fracassé continue si tu veux mais
tu leur prends si tu veux parce que
franchement elle t'a pas rater et du
coup elle dit à alma pas rater bon ben
alors oui donc à la plus après sur les
points les pois mauvais après l'es10 que
le naturel avait cassé le tuerait la
mairie parce qu'ils sont obligés de
refaire les prises que il ya les caméras
les micros ils sont obligés de refaire
des prix sous tendre ça casse le côté
festif de la mairie est qu après qu
après notamment aussi l'église avec mona
faudra pour faire d un album de mariage
kim n'a pas pu avoir lieu parce que les
caméras qu'elle est invaincue à
terroriser les flash nand qui n'avait
jamais payé plus de 1000 euros pour
avoir un album photo qui n'a jamais eu
qui n'ont jamais eu des choses comme ça
et qu'après le dîner au fait croire
qu'il ya une ambiance festive on leur
demande seulement candidate pendant un
quart d'heure de faire nous manger on
s'en faire semblant de dire comment
théâtre dansé et le résultat ne se
cassent et elles vont flux d'eau alors
flore qui est arrivé à bout ça s'est
très bien passé
tout à fait on a très bien organisé
s'est bien passé ça avait une très bonne
mine plein air qui m'a qui m'a apporté
la prestation pour lequel j'avais payé
donc enfin j'ai eu un très très beau
mariage
alors je reconnais pas du tout tous les
témoignages que j'entends ça vous a pas
demandé de refaire des choses tout ça
alors on a vu ces textes c'est un peu
chaud avec les autres prétendantes
regardez ce côté magasin plan n'est pas
du tout convenu c'est pas possible
il a parlé pamiers
un touriste en prépa des marques gm par
le haut et est très beau mais le bas
j'aime parles-tu là j'aime pas ça c'est
trop brouillon trop grossier calamy des
fleuves et des pétales trois bougies et
c'est tout quoi y avait deux crever de
poser sur une salade une terrine
c'était une entrée c'était pas possible
j'ai pas compris cité la question est en
fait je pensais que c'était
minh tâm découvrir j'ai pas compris que
la caisse comptait réchaud l ai eu très
chaud
ap
[Musique]
alors vous m'avez depuis la diffusion
d'émissions ça se passe pas du tout
comme pour ceux là où ça s'est très bien
passé vous il paraît que votre commerce
a coulé oui donc pourquoi si c'est un
fait c'est terminé pour vous non je
continue à organiser des mariages mais
c'est vrai que les quotas que j'avais
précédemment
ben légende téléphoner en disant qu'on a
eu dans l ombre à mort contre à chaque
lan suite à l'émission et en plus de ça
latéraux diffusé le 1er janvier 2018 qui
annule ans après avoir vu l'émission ils
disent vous ai vu en fait je trouve nul
et donc j'annule non c'est pas ça je
vous mets un exemple en ont donné
l'exemple
parce que oui non c'est surtout moi ce
que je critique cela on va dire l'équipe
de ne pas devoir l'epad équipes l'équipe
de production à l'équipe était
magnifique
oui la société de production par contre
et le montage qui a été fait derrière
alors alors ça c'est le montage à la
suite de l'émission j'avais perdu
beaucoup de chiffres d'affaires et vous
avait divorcé
là
salah laouar en fait il a d'autres c'est
que j'étais j'ai perdu du club du blé
mais en maintenant je divorce est
salarié vous donne un exemple justement
alors ouais ouais ben vous avez été
victime d'une séquence très à charge
contre hollande ou flore qui est là
puisque vous avez fait le même n'hésitez
pas non plus à vous dire qu'est ce que
vous pensez lui et c'était pas la
grosseur tant d'entre vous deux on m'a
demandé mon avis le donnait à et de
manière très correcte très visionner
comme sentiments pour toi c'est pas
comment aller
du coup on entend qu'il fait pas de
caméra après du passif est tellement
bien faire momo il a un prix un peu trop
de place
depuis le début il a un peu oublié que
c'était pas son mariage frank lowy
d'arrêt avec des chansons moi je vois
des mômes ourtal casquette les parties
si je n'étais pas louper il achète quoi
encore cette impression comme ont été
présents partout on sait lui qui étiez
les ficelles et mal s'en mêler alors
c'est vrai vous qui fiez pas au golf on
va pas s'en tirer alors mohamed donc
vous est ce que l'émission est bidonné
si vous nous rejoignez 4 mariages pour
une lune de miel
ils ont enquêté sur cette émission sur
tf1 organise des mariages est-ce que
c'est bidonné au pas il nous reste deux
minutes 1 les chéris gilles verdez il ya
une journaliste qui suit chaque
participant et qui dit quand vous dites
je n'aime pas la robe arrête tape plus
fort ça va pas donc on a dit écrivez
juste une question est ce que les mariés
ont le même budget pour organiser leurs
mains non non non non c'est un peu
différent si vous rémunérez alors il
semblait répondre oui on a énuméré les
deux j aimais les connaît c'est pas
grand chose mais mon flanc juste où est
ce qu'il ya eu du bidonnage highway ce
qu'on vous a dit il besoin était
suffisamment méchant tu es tu es méchant
ne peut pas raconter n'importe quoi
mais voilà parce que sans regarder début
à la fin là on vous a montré des
séquences mais du début à la fin quand
vous regardez donc l'émission ça n'a pas
du tout été comme ça donc j'ai été très
correct très courtoise j'ai dit la
vérité
contrairement à monsieur c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il s'en mord les doigts au
jour d'aujourd'hui et qu'il a dû avoir
ça on est dans un débat dont il avait
raison c'est pas bien passé pour lui
c'est parce que c'est l'image qu'il a
renvoyé le retiendrait que j'ai une
question
j'ai une vidéo d'après moi m juste les
questions est-ce que sur les notes on
vous influence ça c'est ce qu'on met
alors en dehors on nous enfume enfin on
nous dit on nous dit de manière totale
ou non non non on nous dit de manière
très courtoise de 2,2 c'est de ne pas
donner une note en dessous de 7 à ça
c'est la base et m'a demandé pourquoi
tout le monde est basé royo rue vers des
ses erreurs est de retour dès qu'ils
voient effectivement de pendant
l'interview c'est à dire après le
mariage parce qu'il faut pas oublier que
une fois encore qu'il ya une célébration
du mariage
à partir de là on nous met dans un
studio vont monter ce jour
d'enregistrement montée et des bas il
dit justement développé développer
développer et je ne laisse pas de dire
développer développer développé et a
ordonné qu'on donne une note à bas bruit
et cela continue à développer
donc comme on en donne en baisse les
notes directement les scénaristes mais
non c'est normal mais c'est flore arrête
non
on m'a demandé de venir pour débattre
inarrêtable jeudi nous a jamais
influencé juste on n'a pas droit de
mettre toute cette voilà donc comment tu
as fait et disent quoi c'est pas ça
décolle dans quel but on vient c'est
s'il l'avait si la finalité est plus
fort que le reste et bar à forcer pour
la vénalité
oui à quatre vols lune de miel et telle
magouille et oui à 90 %
non seulement nous avons remercions la
production on essaye de leur donner un
côté fils gould au programme et ils ont
tourné un spécial invités ou là ils vont
mettre en place une note
une hotte pour la mariée habite et qui
sait le mieux comportés et ça ils
essayent de le tester en france pour
donner un coup de feu alors là on est on
est rejeté très très vite j'étais j'ai
fait un défilé à marrakech lors de
soirées suis tombé sur une émission de
quatre mariages et une lune de miel mais
à allemand oui eh ben il va présenter à
des fins professionnelles qui étaient là
et qui jugeait aussi le mariage
oui en france on a enlevé une partie
l'ensemble quoi pas je suis pas sûr de
la foule
merci clore la rigueur